Why, why, why
did you destroy the palace
? This place
was supposed to become a symbol of peace.
has taken root
Class structures have taken in
Grow inequality Soon you'll be at war with what accepts you
That's what I forbid That's
not what I mean
You
've been doing that with humans forever  As a
symbol to be revered, I
always thought you were moving within a personal framework,
but
you're saying that you're going to be swallowed by a human-like framework.
I endured the unsightliness and killed you
Woke up from my dreams and
let me say, if you can do it, try it
[Music]
Even I knew this was not a good
flow  The food brought by was so delicious
[music]
That's how we
decided to go to each other.
I
didn't get involved
with people.Isn't he a guy who got along so well that he quarreled
? Mr. Kobayashi, did you hear what I was talking about
?